so what I did at Carnegie Mellon was
speech recognition what I do today
is helping startups in mobile computing
so there really isn't much overlapping
what I do but it turns out as I thought
about it there's a huge amount of
overlap between what I learned at
Carnegie Mellon and how I'm doing what
I'm doing today so for those of you who
don't know I left Google about a little
over two years ago and when I realized
that my largest legacy at Google China
was probably going to be that people I
helped develop and those who left and
started companies and are amazingly
successful because it was a very
interesting confluence of times where
the in China the talent is so amazing so
hard-working and so hungry for success
and the Chinese market is so
fast-growing and the economy as well and
the and the the opportunities are just
so many and the cost of doing a start-up
is lower than ever in history and the
value of the startups whether it's in
revenue users or market cap is higher
than ever in history so when all of
these things are aligned is like a
perfect storm that the people I had the
good fortune to have mentored and helped
at Google China when they were given a
nice platform and learned about the
latest technologies products trends and
combine that with the mentorship that I
and my team provided them became China
among China's best entrepreneurs so I
thought gosh you'll be a lot more fun to
do this full-time to help find the
greatest potential entrepreneurs in
China and help them explain understand
the trends that are going on selects the
hottest sub areas that will go through
the most explosive growth help them
build the teams that they need and give
them the first round or two or three of
capital
and help them become the next Baidu
Tencent or what have you from China so
that's what I set out to do September
2009 and in the last two years and two
months we are very proud that we have
funded over 40 companies and only less
than 10% have failed and more than more
than 15% have received funding of about
10 million dollars or more and the
collective valuation of these 43
companies is now nearly half a billion
dollars so it's definitely realizing the
dream that when you have great people
great ideas great innovation and a very
quick quickly growing market it really
is a lot of fun and an amazing
experience and it will be very
successful and profitable for these
young people that we find that when
every day when I go to work I can see
the sparkle in their eye and that they
see their every day their dream is one
step closer to being realized and that
and helping these people innovate and
create great products is probably the
most fun I've ever had in my career and
this is really amazing
so if you know people who want to start
companies come and come and tell me but
really what I'm here to talk about is
what it was from the Carnegie Mellon
days that was extremely helpful most
helpful to me at innovation works and
I'll just tell you a few stories of as
when I entered Carnegie Mellon basically
the three most important things that I
learned in Carnegie Mellon and how they
were very helpful to to my career and in
particular to innovation works
I remember in 1983 since president
Cohen's already spoiled my my age - all
of you that was 1983 was when I showed
up on campus and the first professor I
met was the late Professor Nico
who was that at the time the chair of
the computer science department and as I
asked him what the expectations were of
me like any nice Chinese student now he
asks the professor
what is your expectation of me and Nico
said to me and I remember to the state
that I expect you to be the best you the
best in the world in the area of your
PhD thesis and that was really shocking
to me that a 21 year old can dream that
in four or five years time to be the
best in the world in anything but he
explained to me that that's the
expectation of Carnegie Mellon that and
also it's not the best in computer
science but in a specific area in which
I worked but at the same time he told me
that while I would take away from
Carnegie Mellon the most valuable gift
was not that PhD thesis but the process
in building that thesis that the journey
would be more important than the
destination that the journey would teach
me how to think how to solve problems
how to work with people how to work
independently and that would be the
largest gift and today almost 30 years
later I find that those were truly words
of wisdom and they have really
significantly changed me so those words
at innovation works were also words that
I apply to my work all the time that I
realized that in a large domain of
possible investments that we could make
there are a few pockets that are really
really really important for example
building an Android ecosystem in mobile
and the approach we took was basically
what Niko taught me to go find every
smart person and inspire them to build
that best product within the Android
ecosystem so we would use our technical
expertise to pick the small domain find
great people and what they would work on
within that small domain and everybody
can be the best in
all domain and we want to encourage
inspire and help and enter and coach
these people to pick that small domain
and be the very best and that's how
Google Facebook Microsoft and great
companies were made and that was my
first lesson that was is tremendously
helpful to me and innovation works the
second biggest lesson I learned who
basically happened the second day at
Carnegie Mellon after talking to Nikko I
went to class and then the professor
said well for the next month there are
actually no classes you are about to
enter the marriage process and what
marriage process was at school of
computer science at Carnegie Mellon was
that the students would get to sit there
and listen to the hundred of the best
professors in computer science pitched
to them why they should pick them as
their professor and supervisor and this
was unheard of especially to a Chinese
student that is not a teacher who picks
the student but the other way around and
that month in itself if for no other
thing really gave confidence to that
class of thirty people that we were
respected that we were empowered that we
were in control of our destiny that we
got to pick what we were passionate
about and that was something very very
special and that one month was probably
the most fun I've had before funding
innovation works and and during that
month I absorbed everything that
teachers had to say and eventually I was
fortunate enough to pick Raja Reddy
as my PhD supervisor and of course
perhaps everybody wanted to pick a great
professor that it can't just be a
one-way process so the professor would
have to say well you know one person
picked me fine I'll take him but if six
people picked me maybe I have to pick
only two of the six to sort of make it
fair so basically people were only
guaranteed of getting it maybe your top
three professors but not your top one
but I was lucky to get my top one
and I really treasure that opportunity
to do what I'm passionate about and
feeling empowered and that gave me the
confidence and energy to be the best
that I could be in the following four
and a half years after which I got my
PhD so how did I use that marriage
process at innovation works we actually
add innovation works go to the top 13
universities in China and recruit every
year and we since we are an incubator
and investment company we don't hire
engineers but our portfolio companies do
these 40 companies do so what we do is I
would go to the 13 schools the process
is I would give a speech about
innovation works and what we funded and
then I would get everybody excited and
say our and then have them take a
written exam so that part I didn't learn
it's kind of given Ellen that might not
be good go so well for recruiting but
when you have 2,000 applicants per
university you had to do something for
the screening so we gave a written exam
2,000 people would take it and the top
100 who scored got to face two rounds of
face-to-face interviews and we would
pick on the average another 25 from that
100 and at that point we got the 25
people in the room and then we did the
marriage process except this is China
everything was fast so it was instant
dating so so we just had our portfolio
companies that were still hiring go up
stage one at a time to these 25 students
and said at the end of which said well
you get to pick the top three and we
guarantee you will get into one of the
three and that's almost the Carnegie
Mellon school of computer science
marriage process replicated bit for bit
in our campus recruiting of course when
everybody picks a company they can't
take everybody so the same thing about
the tops reapplied and that I can tell
was tremendous because for the students
to take a chance on a random company was
just too much but to be able to listen
to ten or eight different companies
present and to be able to pick and get
one of the top three that was liberating
and and empowering it made them feel
valued trusted and and and they got to
pick what they were passionate about
because the core essence of this is when
people work on what they're passionate
about they their power is amplify three
or five times when you work on something
you hate
your passion is probably your your
output is probably reduced by 50% or
more so that's how we using what I
learned that Carnegie Mellon helped
people find what they're passionate
about at innovation works today so so
that's the second thing I took and the
third and last thing had to do with my
adviser Raj Reddy I remember I studied
for one year under Raj and he was a
wonderful teacher
he showed me how he wanted me he
suggested me some ideas on how to do my
PhD thesis he told me to do speech
recognition and to try to use expert
systems which at the time was the
hottest technology after one year I I
realized that was really a dead end that
speech recognition was wonderful but
expert systems was not going to scale so
I went back to him and I said Raj I
really think I'd love to work on speech
recognition I love studying under you
but let me can you let me use
statistical methods to collect data
train discriminant models and do pattern
recognition using hidden Markov models
instead of using the expert systems so
he asked me a bunch of questions at the
end of which he said Kai fool I don't
agree with you but I support you and
that really threw me off my chair
because from a Chinese education
it seemed if you don't agree with me you
shouldn't support me if you agreed with
me you should support me but then he
explained that he believed that
everybody is equal in that in the
pursuit of science and that everybody is
entitled to his or her opinion and that
if he or she got to work on what he or
she is very passionate about and then
they're much more likely to become
successful and that he would rather
support me to do something he didn't
think would work then to force me to do
it his way which also may not work and
also I didn't believe in and and he
wasn't just using words to make it sound
good but instead he bought me the
fastest machines
he helped me secure from DARPA the
largest database and he introduced me to
experts who could teach me about
statistics because that was in his
particular area and with all that I was
able to create the first speaker
independent continuous speech
recognition system and was able to get
my PhD successfully from from Carnegie
Mellon and and from that whole lesson
what I learned was that it's not just
when you let support people to do what
they love to do whether or not you
believed in it it was not just that you
are magnanimous you're generous but that
is a very much valued style of
leadership that I realize smart people
and everyone at CMU was smart and
everyone innovation works is smart smart
people want to be trusted empowered to
do things that they love to do and to do
it their way so that the best thing that
a boss could ever do is to trust and
empower and coach and support and help
their employees become successful that I
learned from from Raj that the the the
most important thing about management is
to provide an environment that you would
like to that you yourself would like to
work in to be the kind of boss that you
yourself would like to work for and that
you yourself being a smart person want
that someone to trust you support you
give you resources and let you do what
you love and that I think is really the
essence the entire essence of innovation
works and that innovation works we find
these entrepreneurs show them what the
industry trends are what the
opportunities are and then we would help
them find their own
product idea and passion and then we
would help them set up their company pay
their taxes and payroll we have a team
that would help them design their
product with support on how to do best
UI design we have a Human Resources team
that will help with campus recruiting
all the way to headhunter force EXO
types of positions but at the end of the
day all that we do was really just doing
what Raj taught me that if you want the
smart people to be that the best that
they can be let them work on what
they're passionate about and give them
your unwavering 100% support so those
were the three most important things I
learned from Carnegie Mellon that we
should be the best that we can be
anybody can be the best in a particular
domain that people should work on what
they're truly passionate about and that
and that the ability to choose is
unbelievable and unbelievably empowering
and lastly the best way to manage people
is to provide an environment where they
can get the full support of what they
want to do and that you manage people
the way that you want to be managed
thank you